So, now we're in a good position to finally define this notion
of NP-completeness that I mentioned in the beginning of the unit.
We can say some problem X is NP-complete if it satisfies two properties.
First, it has to be NP-hard, meaning that nothing
in NP is harder then X. Which is to say that if you could
solve X in polynomial time, you could use it to solve everything in NP in polynomial time.
And the second important property is that X
itself is in NP. So its in the set and its as hard as anything in the set.
So, it is in fact the hardest in this set.
And though it may seem a little weird to satisfy
both of these at the same time, there are actually tons of problems known to be NP-complete.
Very often when you go to solve some, to develop some kind of algorithm to solve
a problem and there just doesn't feel like there is anyway to get a foothold
on it, uh, its a good idea to check: is NP-hard and is it in NP?
If so, its NP-complete. And, uh, at this point now, tons of problems are known to be NP-complete.
There is lists, there are online websites that list lots of problems.
There's wonderfully written books that layout problem after problem after problem.
And sometimes they are really natural extensions of each other and
sometimes its really quite interesting to see how they are connected to each other.
Saying that some problem is NP-complete tells us an awful lot about that problem.
So, let's imagine there is some problem called graph partitioning - which is a real problem.
And it is related to social networks.
But, I'm not going to tell you what it is, but I will tell you that its NP-complete.
Even if you don't know what it is, there are some things that you do know by the virtue of the fact
that is is NP-complete, assuming that you believe me, you'd know the following:
which of these, check all that apply, which of these do you know?
if I tell you that graph-partitioning is NP-complete does that mean its
NP-hard and therefore a polynomial time solution for that problem
solves everything in NP.
Do we know that the problem clique can be reduced to it?
Given what we've said so far about what we've said so far about clique.
Do we know that graph partitioning is in NP, and therefore an exponential time solution would exist?
Do we know that it can be reduced to SAT, based on the things I've told you about SAT in this unit?
Check all that apply.